there's a lot of faster this year's
Mobile World Congress focused on the
SmartWatch sector with many of the
device makers keeping a firm eye on that
March the ninth date when apple is
expected to launch its first SmartWatch
the big question is can any of the
device makers here really complete
chinese mobile john far away cause quite
a stir when it released its far away
watch at the start of the Mobile World
Congress and here it is it's very much
combining fashion and technologies got a
genuine leather strap which you're going
to feel many smartwatches it's got a
nice smooth interface here it uses
google's android wear operating system
it's got a six extra sensor and it's got
a heart rate monitor on the back so this
is LG's newly launched urbane LTE
SmartWatch it's what an antenna built
into the strap which means that it acts
as a phone you have to have your
smartphone on you it's also got NFC
technology so you can make payments with
this in cafes and bars got lots of apps
including health and fitness tracking
it's going to launch new South Korea in
two months and we still waiting for a
date for the European or global launch
as well and the small washers do really
take off in a big way the Swiss have
thrown their hats into the ring with
this it's the micro nose zphone it packs
in a sim card so it's basically a phone
and a watch combined and it uses android
operating system so you've got all your
apps as well very different from usual
swiss heritage watches